Star Wars: The Last Jedi is one of the biggest
cinematic spectacles of the year. In addition
to returning characters like Luke, Rey, Finn,
and Kylo Ren, the eighth film in the Skywalker
saga will add several new faces, like Kelly
Marie Tran, who's been referred to as the
"biggest new part" of The Last Jedi.
In the film, she portrays Rose, a member of
the Resistance who works side-by-side with
Finn.
Kelly Marie Tran might not be a household
name yet, but it won't be long before her
face is gracing thousands of action figures
and posters. Nonetheless, she might look awfully
familiar to Star Wars fans, and with good
reason. Here are just a few of the places
you may have seen her before.
Web Shorts
Kelly Marie Tran grew up in San Diego, California,
and caught the acting bug early on. In high
school, she took to the stage, appearing in
plays, musicals and later, alongside improv
comedy troupes throughout her education at
UCLA.
She eventually transitioned to doing digital
shorts and earned her first starring role
as a cast member of the YouTube comedy series
Ladies Like Us. A meta-commentary of sorts,
the web saga followed the adventures of three
would-be up-and-comers from an all-female
comedy troupe. The series explored the challenges
of seeking out fame and fortune in the wannabe-saturated
world of Los Angeles. And each webisode also
explored or parodied standard character tropes
like personal insecurity, bad boyfriends,
and expectations foisted on women by Hollywood
and the media.
Tran's quirky character charms the audience,
and the show's hip-hop-fueled vibe and crude
elements are reminiscent of the ladies from
Broad City.
About a Boy
Tran next made her mark on the acting world
by landing a small role on the short-lived
NBC series About a Boy. Based on Nick Hornby's
novel, the show starred David Walton and Minnie
Driver. And although the series only lasted
for two seasons, it garnered a cult following
and above-average critical ratings. The one-camera
sitcom shadowed man-child singer-songwriter,
Will, as his awkward relationship with his
neighbors upset his otherwise libertine lifestyle.
On the show, Tran popped in twice as Marguerite,
a thoroughly inattentive babysitter. It was
hardly the breakout role for the young actress,
but it did allow her to flex a few comedic
muscles on a major network-based sitcom.
PSA days
As part of her foray into comedy, Tran also
starred in several madcap webisodes for College
Humor, creating some memorably amusing sketches.
Among the wittiest clips was her role as a
member of a political correctness-monitoring
Asian council in "Are You Asian Enough?" She
also dropped by a startup app developer i
n the poignant yet funny "Why Net Neutrality
Matters (and What You Can Do To Help)."
Of course, not all of her PSAs were quite
as hilarious as those. She also appeared in
one the anti-smoking Truth campaign ads -- and,
ironically enough, it's one that had a Star
Wars twist to it.
"I only smoke when I …"
"Oh It's a trap!"
Pub Quiz
As Tran built her voice and her personal brand
on network TV, the burgeoning actress landed
roles on several web series, like Hope & Randy—where
she played the roommate of the lead couple.
In 2016, she wound up with a major role in
a full-length TV pilot about a band of rowdy
bar trivia junkies. Pub Quiz followed a gang
of screw-ups and their misadventures as they
sought to dominate the liquor-soaked bar quiz
world.
These are all small potato projects, in comparison
to The Last Jedi, but, hey, everybody's gotta
start somewhere.
Thanks for watching! Click the Looper icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel. Plus
check out all this cool stuff we know you'll
love, too!